as we approach one year since the
official start of the pandemic there are
still many unanswered questions about
the coronavirus among them
china's handling of the virus at its
supposed origin
wuhan the city reported its first known
case back in december
2019 and then wuhan went into a strict
lockdown between january and april of
2020
with a population greater than that of
new york city it was one of the largest
quarantines
in history the documentary 76 days
shortlisted for an
oscar tells the stories of health care
workers
and patients in four wuhan hospitals at
the brink of capacity
with too many patients showing up all at
once
76 days is available on paramount plus
the vicom cbs streaming service and
co-director writer and producer hal
wu joins us now how good morning to you
this is an extraordinary
documentary there are no sit-down
interviews there's no
tv news footage brought in it is all
propulsive on the scene coverage
from two anonymous reporters who somehow
got their way
into these four hospitals there in wuhan
when you were taking in the footage
as director was there a moment when you
thought to yourself first of all
whoa this is a big deal and second of
all it's going to go way beyond wuhan
i think i got the first batch of footage
to come in i was in new york
while my co-directors were filming wuhan
i remember
mid february i got the first bunch of
footage i watched it
i was immediately blown away because up
to that point
i had read so much about what was
happening wuhan
and to mostly print me the news media
but
i had never had such a sort of like um
on the wall i fly on the wall evidence
to see what's happening on the on the
front line
so it was really extremely moving and
harrowing at the same time
and i immediately realized i needed to
work with these two to work on the film
so
here in the us we we always hear about
restrictions in china
the government cracking down on
journalists people not getting access
and then here this documentary has
extraordinary access
how were your two anonymous reporters on
the ground able to obtain it
my co-director wish chen he's a video
reporter for esquire china but he wasn't
actually sent by esquire to cover the
beat
he's also our aspiring documentary
filmmaker himself
so as soon as he learned about the
lockdown he just went down there
but he was turned away by four different
hospitals before he found
through personal connection to embed
himself with a medical team that was
being sent from elsewhere in china to
support a local hospital
and the local hospital seeing him
arriving together with medical team
for a while they thought he was working
for the medical team that's how he got
access and with my other co-director
anonymous
he's a photogenic photojournalist for a
local newspaper
and he was he was basically assigned to
take photos
for their print news stories that's how
he gained access it's amazing you know
politics global politics american
politics chinese politics
are kind of outside the purview of the
footage except for one moment on the
street where you can hear a loudspeaker
uh say people shouldn't believe rumors
we have to pull together as a collective
given that politics is put aside in this
when you were editing it you had to
consider the bigger picture and i'm
curious
uh the president of china praises the
country's handling
of the pandemic there would you agree
um i think both countries there are
something that the government did right
and also some
something lacking in their kobe 19
response that's just
not just happening in china but also
here as well because i was in new york
witnessing how
the u.s completely failed in its early
response to cover 19
and the panic it has it was causing
among the population here in new york
city but as i was making this film i
think
i truly just want to value the um the
rare
the raw footage coming from the front
line and also
the extremely human story individual
human story
uh that's um that that's captured in
their footage
at the same time i just feel like right
now since we're still living through the
pandemic
it's a little bit too early to draw any
conclusion in terms of
whether any government did what right
well how will it's extraordinary footage
captured under extraordinary risk from
two collaborators in wuhan china thank
you very much for bringing to us
it's a great documentary and we
appreciate you being on this morning
as we mentioned you can watch 76 days on
the new viacom cbs streaming service it
is called paramount plus